non on y va c'est parti toussaint dehors
greg le millionnaire marjolaine et l'a
tellement l'oscar qu'elle a une seule
émission est la remarque de m j'ai
appris à plat après j'ai appris qu'en
fait quand tu as fait greg le
millionnaire pardon mais tu savais tout
oui tu savais qu'il n'était pas agréé il
savait tout est pas et des millionnaires
et je crois qu histoire c'est qu'en fait
pardon mais tu avais un peu chez pas
commandite est pour lui un plan cul dans
la maison que la vocation avait c'était
quoi on peut du tout j avais été en
vacances d'été en attendant cette maison
et ça appartenait en fait à rome et amis
d'un ex voilà donc tu arrives dans la
maison qu'à prod a loué la très bien
qu'elle n'appartient pas à greg l'année
et qui a des portes qui sont fermées à
clé tchèque des cadenas comme quand tu
vois dans nos locations est indicatif le
jeu bah j'ai en fait on m'avait déjà
prévenu à la veille du départ qui était
prévenu jaime 6 bounce il ya les
émissions route avaient prévenu qu'ils
étaient pas eu lieu comme avait dit
j'étais dans la listing on fait le
listing en fait des candidates ouais et
on m'avait dit que du coup c'est à ibiza
je voyais pas trop en fait effectivement
donc on est parti à ibiza et donc j'ai
compris tout de suite que et en plus je
le connais c'est grave mais non en fait
avant il était gogo dance en merde tu
t'es pas les aime tous dansé
pour les trucs mais aux deux
milliardaires et les milliardaires
arrête les conneries c'est une question
d'ego go avec moi
alors regardez la présentation la ville
à l'époque des marges allen gregory est
un garçon simple il vit grâce à des
chantiers et des petits boulots il va
échanger sa vie modeste contre une vie
trépidante de multi lignes d'un genre
particulier désormais riche il doit
apprendre les codes de son nouveau monde
avant que greg le millionnaire ne
rencontrent ces vins prétendantes
général parmi nous doit y avoir
certainement des retours
trouvera-t-il celle qui l'aimera pour
lui et non pour ses millions
[Musique]
c'est accueillant les trois dernières
en quatrième cinquième et a eu ce dîner
mythique on s'en souvient a tous bien
sûr ou ou greg était de nature mais de
partout
balala
quand même
l'émotion des marins français reste que
ce soit
c'est terrifiant
c'est que je suis là je suis sûr partout
je suis dur par tous là
c'est durant sept jours comme tous les
sens du terme
qu'est ce que j'aimerais pouvoir dire ça
encore
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure c'est une
émission bien monté
qu'il y avait garé histoires et des
coucheries dans l'émission je comprenais
on était dans des maisons c'est par wim
on va dans autant on peut se rapprocher
on peut personnes avec personne non
parce que c'est à l'époque savaient pas
comme loft et tout ça au site et des
caméras c'était des équipes de tournage
qui venait le matin ouais qui tournait
qui repartaient et tout le monde se
sépare et on n'était pas dans les bars
que la mort c'est bon elle a lieu on
n'était pas une bonne dans les mêmes
endroits donc on était dans une villa et
greg était apparent sait pas ou alors
c'est un tel succès qu'après tape
tournée mission marjolaine et les
millionnaires là en revanche tu couches
la
connaître non sur les dix-sept j'en ai
choisi tiens oui mais toi
jane eyre j'en ai j'en ai choisi qu'un
seul à choisir qu'un c'est bien quand
même si cette émission effectivement
c'était le concept absolument est alors
derrière changement de vie totale là tu
deviens c'est le petit costume working
girl pour ce qu'on vit le film avec
harrison ford alors non j si un contrat
de avait que tf1 pour ou en fait j'avais
un contrat en fait en tant que cadre
supérieur chez eux on est en fait
supérieur chez eux ouais je pense t cry
4 supérieur en fait à l'époque c'étaient
des contrats d'exclusivité ouais on
appartenait à la chaîne et pendant 6 7
ans en fait j'étais animatrice télé sa
tentacule mian mian a été payé combien
pas moi je peux le dire ouais c'est
alexia laroche joubert moi c'était à
l'époque elle m'avait proposé 1000 euros
pour six mois voilà je suis reparti avec
3000 euros pour trois ans et c'est grâce
à eux que j'ai acheté mon premier
appartement romero par mois oui moi
[ __ ] quand tu penses qu'avec ça
maintenant tu fais la télé pendant six
mois ça fait mal c'était une autre
époque
d'exclusivité c'est quand même quand il
n'aime pas d'émission c'est tous les
mois et touché minimum trente mille
outre en contrebas ici lors été heureux
qu'on n'a pas mais des propositions de
deux émissions différentes de deux
chemins différents ouais
alors diana jones 2 secondes et donc du
coup est donc contraint à subir le
contrat d'gars pourtant j'étais
animatrice télé présenté des émissions
sur les courses de voitures parce que je
fais si pilote de course voilà devant ce
mur dont j'ai présenté des émissions sur
un terrain sur tf6 fin d'émission sur
game one aussi sur les jeux vidéo sur
des moines game one et moi game one
pour nous mais après tout après ses 6 7
ans je suis parti un an aux états unis
ouais et quand je suis revenu j'ai envie
de perdre mon fils j'ai eu un petit
garçon
est en fait en fait moi même ma mère m'a
toujours en fait reprochés ne jamais
avoir fini mes études parce que j'avais
arrêté à 22 ans donc elle m'a dit voilà
on regarde tous tes frères et soeur ils
sont tous avocats médecins en toi tu
fais rien tout ça c'est donc pour elle
en fait j'ai repris mes études
pendant trois ans l'immobilier voilà je
suis arrivé major de promo et lauréate
au concours c'est bien
parce que je peux vous dire que
maintenant tu vend de l'immobilier mais
de l'immobilier de luxe un cécité veut
acheter un truc à 300000 battus voire
plaza ac et non là c'est des trucs à
10,15 millions d'euros on t'a vu à dubaï
dans tout tu vente arrivé tout ça c'est
des mobiles de luxe je fais des tours en
fait on fait du commercial du
résidentiel et de l'hymne du vent de
rien et si on
peut aussi s'occuper de studio tout
comme d'immeubles enfin je veux dire on
a dit noble quelques ébauches de
l'immeuble n'est pas vital septième
numéro de nouna c'est le seul accusé ici
c'est tu vas tu es très heureux s'est
marié non on s'est séparés ya six ans en
mer il ya six ans et
libertaire qui cherche l'amour je
cherche pas spécialement l'amour tu
cherches d'argent de chercher non mais
tu je vais accepter l'idée de vie seul
service à tout le monde dit ça pour ton
bien
que tout le monde doit forcément être en
couple dans le schéma du mari de la
femme de chambre
tu sais pourquoi parce que sinon tu as
ma vie tu rentres chez toi qui m'as
jogging tubulures y est tu t'emmerdes
racontant la personne je suis libre et
tu rencontres un coût qui se trompent
qui fondent et franchement ce que tu me
demander si elle belle
histoire quand même tu es pas non plus
sinon c'est un bébé
factor en octobre novembre décembre
elle est blonde et
il fait de très jolis ce brillant requin
est ce que tu peux parce que là après
beaucoup passer à un autre sujet très
importante et on n'a pas le temps de
tout faire tu regardes cette caméra
c'est pour y en a une gala dit voilà le
gars le garçon de tes rêves et
ressemblerait à qui ça serait quoi vas-y
sapiens a passé tournez manège imagine
toi je suis pas bien égal à quoi
ressemblerait le garçon de vos rêves et
bien soin de mes rêves même là pour moi
non mariés conneries on n'est pas là
mais c'est tout j'ai besoin de rien mais
c'était vraiment lui seul jessica man
city tient ce type dont 6 music
alors grand qu'elle a eu avec moi ouais
j'ai 41 ans d'usagé que toi
physiquement comment faire physiquement
faut qu'ils soient pas trop gros pas
trop gros bras musclés a pas forcément
musclé parce que j'ai remarqué que les
gens qui t'aiment ce qu'ils
voient surtout sympathique n'est pas
trop dominant parce que tu es une femme
de bien si il faut qu'il soit dominant
c'est pas mignon aujourd'hui temps non
mais c'est pas mignon
surtout riesch benzema d'accord non je
suis pas d'accord avec toi à côté